auf dem youtube kanal von phoenix hier
weiter aus dem bundestag wir werden
weiter den bundestag übertrafen ich habe
schon angekündigt es der nächste
tagesordnungspunkt digitaler impfpass
das ist eine initiative der fdp und den
einführenden vortrag sollen die
begründung für diese debatte lieferte
jetzt manuel höferlin aus der fdp
fraktion zur einführung des digitalen
impfpass und ich muss darauf eingehen
frau kollegin während von der spd weil
sie vorhin so passend gesagt haben wir
reden warum reden wir denn da überhaupt
ich finde ehrlich gesagt ehrlich gesagt
dass eine bemerkenswerte bemerkungen
wenn wir menschen sich seit über einem
jahr in ihrer persönlichen freiheit
zurücknehmen um andere menschen in der
gesundheits lage zu helfen
die gesundheit anderer zu schützen und
jetzt wo sie geimpft sind sich darüber
gedanken machen unter welchen
voraussetzungen denn eigentlich ihre
freiheit schränke überhaupt noch
eingeschränkt werden können und die
rechte vielleicht auch wieder ausüben
können und das dokumentiert ist da ist
genau der richtige zeitpunkt ist es
bemerkenswert dass teile der
regierungsfraktionen solch einen
kommentar hier im plenum loslassen
ich möchte das credo eines fdp kollegen
aus dem bayerischen landtag aufgreifen
fakten fakten fakten fakten
liebe kolleginnen kollegen der
bundesregierung hätten sie öfter in den
letzten zeit man auf die vorschläge der
freien demokraten gehören werden wir in
dieser pandemie situation an vielen
punkten ein stück weiter fakt 2 bereits
am 16 oktober 2009 10 hören sie zu am 16
oktober 2019 also vor 555 tagen vor dem
ersten ausbruch eines kopitz hat die
bundestagsfraktion der fdp hier im
plenum einen antrag eingebracht
impfquoten wirksamer höhen
infektionskrankheiten ausrotten da ging
es um die einführung eines digitalen im
fast 80 wochen hatten wir zeit gehabt
aber jetzt fakt 3
eineinhalb jahre später unter massiven
druck der partie menschen entwicklung
ist diese regierung jetzt auf dem weg
sich doch mal gedanken über einen
digitalen im fass zu machen und ich rede
nicht übrigens über den nachweis sondern
ich rede über den eben passt vielleicht
hat es auch noch nicht jeder so ganz
mitbekommen
das alles zeigt wirksame maßnahmen
kommen weil diese regierung immer viel
zu spät
es gibt eine muster von schlafmützigkeit
in dem letzten jahr
das land wird verpflichtet masken zu
tragen und danach macht sich die
regierung gedanken über die beschaffung
der masken das land soll mehr testen die
regierung fängt danach an sich über die
beschaffung von test gedanken zu machen
das land wird einem impfstoff entgegen
und danach wird sich gedanken gemacht
wie dieser impfstoff dann
organisatorisch verimpft werden soll
und jetzt beim digitalen eben fast ein
ähnliches muster meine damen und herren
jetzt nachdem die impfungen herz nachdem
die impfungen angelaufen sind fällt dann
plötzlich auch man könnte ja vielleicht
auch mal richtung digitalen impfpass was
machen es ist ja geplant von langer zeit
dass man in der epa zu integrieren 2022
oder vielleicht auch später wissen ja
waren digital projekte bei
bundesregierung wenn sie geplant sind
nachher auch wirklich realität werden
aber dass ich will auch gar nicht auf
dass schaffung debakel in diesem
zusammenhang näher eingehen
nach monaten des weiterentwicklungen
stillstands bei der korona vanek wird
jetzt der nachweis dort vielleicht
seinen platz finden ich hoffe das
gelingt auch in den letzten wochen und
monaten das muss man ja mal zu geben hat
die churer waren etwas an schwung
gewonnen ich bin da sehr dankbar und
sehr froh drüber
aber es gab auch wirklich eine lange
phase des stillstands und vor allen
dingen der der unterschiedlichen
informations politik dieser
bundesregierung in diesem punkt das ist
ein impfnachweis soll außerdem nachher
durch den impfpass
abgelegt werden abgelöst werden digital
ausschuss erklärt bekommen dass der imf
nachweis dezentral geführt wird der
impfpass nachher in die epa integriert
werden soll auf die frage wie denn dort
das überführt werden sollte konnten wir
noch keine zureichende informationen
bekommen denn die systeme sind gar nicht
so einfach miteinander kompatibel das
spricht auch wieder bände und die
menschen fragen sich kann eigentlich
diese bundesregierung projektmanagement
im it-bereich und sie wissen dass ich
habe das schon öfter gesagt nein es
bleibt das einem standbild übrig wie so
oft bei it-projekten der bundesregierung
sie können it projekte nicht steuern
und sie können offensichtlich auch bei
diesem gesundheitssystem keine it
projekte steuern und damit kommt auch
ein schlechtes krisenmanagement zutage
meine damen und herren die leidtragenden
als abschluss der präsident die leid
tragen und sind die menschen in diesem
land die darauf warten schüler
schülerinnen eltern pfleger ärzten die
gastronomen und die künstlerinnen in
diesem land die darauf warten endlich
wieder auch danke im chinesen oder
negativ getestet wieder ein normales
leben zu beginnen
aber es gibt einen silberstreif am
horizont ball sind bundestagswahlen
herzlichen dank ja so weit jetzt ist der
beginn der debatte über den digitalen
impfpass es war der digital politische
sprecherin der sprecher der fdp mann
höhe verliehen es geht ja darum dass die
spd diesen digitalen spaß vorantreiben
will
vor allen dingen die vollständig
geimpften sollen wieder ihre grundrechte
in anspruch nehmen letzter redner ist
tino sorge vom ausschuss für gesundheit
von der cdu csu bundestagsfraktion
vielleicht haben sie den einen oder
anderen kaffee hat mond zu viel
getrunken und deshalb ein bisschen zu
viel koffein intus aber
der antrag der fdp ist ja ich sage jetzt
bei grundsätzlich gar nicht so schlecht
den einzelnen punkt also wenn wir
darüber reden wie können wir geimpften
beispielsweise ihre freiheitsrechte
möglichst schnell wieder zurückgeben
wenn wir darüber reden wie können wir
auch bei digitale digitalisierung
schneller werden bin ich bei ihnen
können wir sehr gerne über diskutieren
wenn wir aber dann wieder die alte
litanei der fdp hier hören wir haben
schon immer besser gewusst wir werden
schneller gewesen mit uns wäre es toll
gewesen wenn wir damit gestaltet hätten
wären wir jetzt schon viel weiter
dann tut es mir leid herr kollege höhe
verliehen dann kann ich nur noch gehen
denn und das ist ja vorhin hier schon
angeklungen der vor debatte wir führen
jetzt eine stunde hier eine debatte zum
digitalen ebenfalls ist in ordnung kann
man machen ich diskutiere immer sehr
sehr gern über digitalisierung wenn sie
sich aber hier hinstellen und wieder so
tun als sei beim digital impfpass
überhaupt nichts passiert als sei beim
digitalen passen überhaupt noch keine
regelungen da man darf nur daran
erinnern
bereits im märz haben wir uns europaweit
darauf keine wie dieser im spaß aussehen
soll und weil sie gerade
bundesgesundheitsministerin sparen und
in dmg hier wieder mal vorwerfen
es würde nichts passieren bereits im
märz also nahezu parallel hat das bmg im
rahmen einer dringlichen vergabe diesen
impfpass in auftrag gegeben das heißt
das was sie ja anfordern das was ich
hier fordern beschleunigungen man sollte
es auf hochtouren machen das ist bereits
der fall ist läuft auf hochtouren hieß
könnten bei den anpackt hat schon für
erledigt erklären wie gesagt du dir die
rotierende stunde ich freue mich wir
haben bisschen mehr redezeit deshalb
gibt mir das auch die möglichkeit auf
den einen oder anderen punkt ein
bisschen besser einzugehen und zwar auch
auf das thema geimpfte nicht gekämpft
natürlich ist es völlig richtig dass wir
so schnell wie möglich alle wieder unser
normales leben haben wollen
natürlich ist es richtig dass gerade
geimpfte das genesene
ihre grundrechte wieder in vollem umfang
genießen können dürfen grundrecht das
sind freiheitsrecht da sind wir uns doch
völlig einig aber aber herr kollege
berlin
die frage über den digital impfpass und
wie wir geimpften möglichst schnell ihre
grundrechte auch über die ja den digital
impfpass und über die klarstellung dass
keine gefahr von den geimpften mehr
ausgeht dass er nicht mehr infektiös ist
das ist keine rein politische frage die
reden hier über eine wissenschaftliche
frage da geht es um evidenz oder müssen
wir uns gegebenenfalls auch wenn die
signale sehr gut sind wissenschaftlich
die zeit nehmen und nicht vorschnell
irgendwelche dinge beschließen herr
kollege darüber hinaus das will ich hier
auch nochmal sagen wenn sie in die cola
waren abgucken würden es geht ja voran
sicherlich kann man jetzt sich darüber
streiten ob das nicht hätte schneller
gehen können ob man das nicht hätte
besser machen können aber wir kennen
doch alle die debatten die wir hier
geführt haben auch in der öffentlichkeit
bei der frage was soll die cola waren
app können bei der frage wie wird diese
app ausgestaltet racing versus tracking
und insofern glaube ich sind wir da
mittlerweile auf einem sehr guten weg
wir haben jetzt die integration auch bei
der frage kontakt tagebuch auf den weg
gebracht wir haben die fragen mit der
cluster erkennung des check-in verfahren
sind ist alles möglichkeiten die über
einen quelloffenen code auch in die in
die cola net integriert werden und
insofern kann ich uns allen nur raten
dies nicht alles schlecht zu reden weil
dann haben wir keine akzeptanz in der
bevölkerung aber ruhig beim thema
schlechtreden bin liebe kolleginnen und
kollegen wir haben ja auch ein antrag
der afd
ich will da jetzt nicht pauschal
draufhalten ich finde es nur wirklich
bemerkenswert wenn die ganze welt
darüber diskutiert wie wir diese
pandemie möglichst schnell überwinden
können wenn die ganze welt israel
schweden frankreich dänemark alle sich
gedanken machen wie man diese pandemie
begleiten mit digitalen möglichkeiten
möglich
überwinden kann wie man grundrechte
möglichst schnell wieder volle geltung
verschaffen kann
dass ihnen nichts weiter einfällt als
hier zu sagen wir müssen dieses projekt
digital impfpass corona waren app sofort
stoppt also es tut mir leid das ist
nicht nur ignorant ich hätte bei einer
gesagt das ist zutiefst asozial und ich
rate ihnen da auch mal jetzt nicht immer
nur an allen expertisen vorbei zu
argumentieren und nicht immer nur
dagegen zu sein
der sachverständigenrat gesundheit
sollten sie mal lesen das letzte
gutachten hat uns in der politik ins
stammbuch geschrieben das wir beim thema
datennutzung die können wir daten besser
vernetzen
wie können wir daten besser nutzbar
machen um nicht nur versorgungen zu
optimieren um forschungen zu optimieren
sondern gerade in pandemie zeiten mit
digitalen möglichkeiten schneller diese
pandemie zu überwinden und die haben
ganz konkret gesagt nicht das was sie
wollen nämlich zurück ins analoge
zeitalter zettelwirtschaft nein die
haben genau das gegenteil gesagt nämlich
bessere nutzung bessere vernetzung
vernetzung und auch gerade für den
patienten in dessen sinne eine bessere
datennutzung den daten retten leben und
die retten sie nicht ins analog auf
einem zettel aufgeschnitten werden
sondern indem sie digital genutzt werden
liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das gibt
mir die möglichkeit zum schluss doch
noch etwas versöhnlicher zu werden
lieber herr kollege höhe verliehen liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen von der fdp
ich glaube man kann den antrag zumindest
ein stück in die abteilung service
opposition einsortieren
also wir sind uns im ziel einig dass wir
auch mit dem digitalen impfpass
möglichst schnell unser leben wieder
normalisieren neuen dass wir möglichst
schnell auch unsere grundrechte in allen
bereichen zu voller geltung wieder
verhelfen wollen
und insofern glaube ich sind wir uns im
ziel einig werden uns sicherlich über
den weg einigen ich freue mich auch die
beratung vielen dank
[Applaus]
von der cdu csu bundestagsfraktion der
ja die kfd attackiert hat wegen ihres
verhaltens den digitalen welten passt
jetzt kann sich die ard direkt zur wehr
setzen mit michael esken delle aus dem
ausschuss für digitale agenda michael s
von der a s d fraktion
[Musik]
sehr geehrter herr präsident sehr
geehrte kollegen liebe zuschauer im saal
und bei youtube im grunde auch eher
sorge ist es ganz einfach punkt eins
niemand sollte direkt oder indirekt zu
einer impfung gegen das corona virus
gezogen werden punkt 2 niemand sollte
dazu gezwungen werden als bedingung für
die ausübung seiner grundrechte künftig
ein corona im pass vorzeigen zu müssen
wenn wir heute über den digitalen
impfpass debattieren stehen aber genau
diese beiden prämissen in frage denn wir
haben seit beginn des jahres erlebt wie
der digitale corona in spas der
mittlerweile das grüne zertifikat
genannt wird im hauruck-verfahren auf eu
ebene und unter tatkräftiger deutsche
regierungsbeteiligung durchgedrückt wird
wurde und wird aus dem forma wieder das
deutsche parlament
am anfang ging es angeblich nur um die
wiederherstellung der reisefreiheit
es dauerte nicht lange und es wurden
pläne geschmiedet wonach man den
impfpass demnächst auch beim einkauf
oder beim kinobesuch vorzeigen müssen
und bei jeder wortmeldung schwang mit
das konzert und kinobesuche künftig doch
nur noch für geimpfte möglich sein
sollten
passend dazu erleben wir derzeit auch
eine der aufwendigsten impfkampagnen die
die impfrisiken negiert und statt
aufklärung wohliges werbe feeling
verbreitet
in diesem zusammenhang will ich die
bundesregierung hatte auch mal fragen
halten sie es auch nicht für den
ausgesprochenen betrug wenn das
impfkampagnen gesicht günther jauch
medienwirksam auf allen kanälen für die
korona impfung wird kurze zeit später an
krone erkrankt und dann sogar zudem muss
gar nicht geimpft worden zu sein
das ist schon ein starkes stück und für
die bereitschaft der bevölkerung
sicherlich nicht förderlich wenn die
regierung auf solche
taschenspielertricks zurückgreift
außerdem interessiert uns in diesem
zusammenhang auch die höhe des honorars
dass uschi glas für ihren beitrag zur
impfkampagne erhalten hat aber solche
fragen hören sie nicht gerne
sie spielen hier lieber den guten
samariter der den bürgern etwas gutes
tun will
während sie eigentlich was ganz anderes
im sinn haben die impfkampagne und der
digitale corona impfpass werden den
leuten schmackhaft gemacht und hübsch
verpackt man wolle den bürgern auf
diesem weg so schnell wie möglich ihre
freiheit zurück geben haben wir auch
gerade von herrn sorge gehört aber unter
diesen noble erscheinenden vorwand wurde
geplant für den corona impfpass
nationale datenbanken zu erstellen in
denen ihm und testdaten gespeichert
werden sollten
die süddeutsche zeitung berichtete im
märz es ging also um eine bundesweite
datenbank mit den persönlichen
gesundheitsdaten von millionen von
bundesbürgern die einer vielzahl von
gehören dann zur verfügung gestanden
hätten
das hätte ganz erhebliche grundrechts
einschränkungen bedeutet und entsprach
wurde im feuchten traum eines jeden
überwachungs fanatikers aber liebe
regierung wir als opposition machen ja
hier unsere arbeit und passen schon auf
und ich würde sagen auch unser antrag im
märz und unser aufschreit zu diesem
thema in diesem haus war gut genug um
aus dem hätte kein ist werden zu lassen
und ihre pläne zu ändern denn die
einrichtung nationaler impft datenbanken
kommt jetzt doch nicht das hat man sich
in der regierung dann doch wohl nicht
getraut
ich bin froh dass wir hier waren das ist
gut dass die auf dem parlament sitzt
ich möchte nicht wissen was sie sonst ja
alles so wieder durch wegen
nichtsdestotrotz gilt der digitale
kompass wird weiterhin fragen auf
wir als afx die bundestagsfraktion
wünschen uns genauso wie alle anderen
menschen in diesem land dass wir so
schnell wie möglich zur normalität
zurückkehren können die menschen wollen
wieder reisen
wir wollen wieder nachmittags kaffee
trinken mit den freunden die wollen
wieder gemeinsam grillen und es ist
perfide von dieser bundesregierung diese
sehnsucht nach normalität und freiheit
wahlweise als verantwortungslos zu
verurteilen oder roter spaziergänger zu
beschimpfen oder zu kriminalisieren
oder aber diese situation für
persönliche macht interessen auszunutzen
wir haben wenn mir eine sache in den
letzten dreieinhalb jahren auch der
grosse brömer in diesem parlament klar
geworden ist dann geht es dieser
regierung nicht um die menschen nicht um
die wirtschaft nicht nur das klima oder
was auch immer gerade und vogue ist es
geht einzig und allein um macht und
kontrolle der mündige bürger steht ihnen
nur im weg man spürt förmlich ihre lust
an durch regierung das hat man auch an
den regierungsfraktionen gesehen die das
infektionsschutzgesetz hier im bundestag
durchgepeitscht haben das ist aber nicht
die aufgabe der bundesregierung hier
durchzuregieren es ist ihre aufgabe
zuzuhören abzuwägen und entscheidungen
zum wohle des volkes zu treffen ich
denke wir alle sind uns hier einig dass
impfungen ein wichtiger bestandteil bei
der bekämpfung der pandemie
und das ist deswegen die pflicht dieser
bundesregierung ist genügend impfstoff
bereit zu stellen aber es ist eben
braucht die aufgabe der bundesregierung
die rechte von jedem bürger zu achten
die ein impfangebot auch ablehnen
und zwar aus welchen gründen auch immer
denn es geht uns als parlamentarier
einfach nichts an was die bürger da
draußen möchten ob sie sich jetzt impfen
lassen möchten
aus etwa gesundheitlichen gründen das
ablehnen oder es schlicht und ergreifend
nicht wollen wir alle haben hier im
parlament kein recht darüber über eine
so höchstpersönliche entscheidung zu
urteilen oder leute sogar zu diffamieren
und auch wenn das hier so manchen nicht
gerne hören mag es ist eine völlig
legitime entscheidung sich über
impfrisiken zu sorgen und einen
impftermin bauch abzunehmen
nun werden sie hier wieder sagen dass
das ja gar nicht in frage gestellt wird
haben wir ja gerade schon mehrfach
wieder gehört das sind aber nichts
anderes als schönen worten ihre taten
sprechen nämlich eine ganz andere
sprache
privilegien für geimpfte sind immer
wieder im gespräch wir fragen uns was
ist denn jetzt eigentlich mit den nicht
geimpften sind jetzt vogelfrei wir als
auf die bundestagsfraktionen haben diese
bundesregierung bei verschiedenen
gelegenheiten gefragt wie sie denn eine
diskriminierung aufgrund des impfstatus
unterbinden will
sowohl im plenum als auch in den
ausschüssen wir haben jeweils keine
antwort erhalten
wir fordern daher von der
bundesregierung dass sie die
diskriminierung von nicht geimpften
mittels eines gesetzes unterbindet kurz
gesagt wenn sie vor corona ohne impfpass
ins kino kino gehen konnten
sollten sie auch jetzt und in zukunft
ohne impfpass ins kino gehen können und
es kann nicht sein dass die regierung
hier lapidar erklärt man dass man
grundrechts einschränkungen für gifte
nicht mehr aufrecht erhalten können und
damit gleichzeitig postuliert dass
ungeimpfte derlei einschränkungen weiter
hinnehmen müssen
geben sie den menschen ihre freiheit
zurück es liegt in der verantwortung
jedes 1
ob er sich impfen lassen möchte oder
nicht und ob er dieses risiko eingeht
oder auch nicht man nennt das allgemeine
handlungsfreiheit das ist ein grundrecht
und diese bundesregierung hat die
pflicht diese rechte zu achten und zu
schützen und nach wie vor tut sie das
nicht deshalb lehnen wir es ab den
digitalen corona impfpass zum maß aller
dinge zu machen
herzlichen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
so dieser digitale ins paz das war ein
antrag der fdp vorantreiben diesen
digitalen spaß unverzüglich individuelle
freiheit wiederherstellt und die
wirtschaft stark und auch da jetzt der
gegenantrag der afg fraktion die sagt
die korona impfpflicht durch diese tür
verhindern das heißt also digitale in
fonds oder eine krone in richtung gehen
der tür
die einführung dieses umfasse stoppt
netzgeräten aber den sabine dittmar von
der spd fraktion
sehr geehrter herr präsident liebe
kolleginnen und kollegen wir beraten
heute anträge zum digitalen impfpass die
afg ignoriert in ihrer polemik nach wie
vor dass geimpfte einen rechtlichen
anspruch darauf haben dass der
impfstatus dokumentiert wird ob das
digital oder analog erfolgt ist erstmal
nachrangig die fdp die fdp wiederum
fordert die einführung eines digitalen
im spa sind deutschland und digitales
einreise management und die rücknahme
kompanie bedingten grundrechts
einschränkungen
all diese themen werden bereits intensiv
diskutiert oder befinden sich längst in
der umsetzung es hätte daher keine
antrag ist der fdp bedürfe meine damen
und herren auch für die spd fraktion ist
die rücknahme der grundrechte
einschränkungen für vollständig die
impfte bürgerinnen von immenser
bedeutung
und deshalb haben wir im vierten
bevölkerungsschutz gesetz auch die
bundesregierung ermächtigt durch
rechtsverordnungen die ihr zustimmung
des bundestages bedarf erleichterungen
und ausnahmen vom geboten und verboten
für immunisiert oder negativ getestete
vorzulegen das robert koch institut
stellt sie infektiosität fest dass das
risiko einer virus übertragung 15 tage
nach vollständiger impfung geringer ist
als bei vorliegen eines negativen
angedient schnelltest bei symptomen
losen infizierten personen und aus
diesem grund haben bereits einige
bundesländer spontan fällt mir
brandenburg berlin oder rheinland-pfalz
ein auf ihre verordnungen bezüglich der
qualität pflicht für vollständig die
impfte angepasst und das ist auch gut so
aber was wir brauchen sind
bundeseinheitlichen regelungen und
deshalb erwarten wir nun eine zügige
eine zügige vorlage einer
bundesverordnung und das instrument der
verordnung hat auch den vorteil schnell
auf neue wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse
reagieren zu können und die sind bei der
colonia impfung bekanntermaßen im fluss
und es gibt auch noch eine menge offene
fragen
die bisherigen erkenntnisse zur
infektiosität basieren auf den daten der
impfstoffe die bislang in der eu
zugelassen sind sind diese annahmen und
erkenntnisse auch auf neue impfstoffe
übertragbar
oder wie lange kann man bei einer
durchgemachten erkranken von einer
ausreichend immunantwort ausgehen und
wie wird diese zeitliche limitierung
dokumentiert was ist mit den impf durch
prüfen die wir immer wieder erleben und
morgen die mutanten auf das
infektionsgeschehen und auf die
immunität sie sehen es gibt noch einiges
zu beantworten aber entscheidend ist
entscheidend ist dass wir jetzt mit dem
impfen zügig vorankommen und die f
und die kids wurden in den letzten 14
tagen haben sich da wirklich erfreulich
entwickelt mehr als 23 millionen
menschen sind erst das sind über 20
prozent und das kolleginnen und kollegen
das gibt uns doch hoffnung und eine
perspektive für den sommer und natürlich
natürlich wird jeder einzelne in fluren
sprechen dokumentiert das ist gesetzlich
geregelt bislang analog in den bekannten
gelben impfbuch ab 22 dann auch im
digitalen elektronischen impfbuch als
teil der elektronischen patientenakte
und weil die fdp immer wieder darauf
zurück kommt die digitale
instrumentation in der eper hätte nicht
vorgezogen werden können auch wenn wir
uns dass grundsätzlich alle natürlich
gewünscht hätten
aber selbst wenn es so wäre würde es gar
keinen sinn machen für den von der fdp
verfolgten zweck oder wollen sie künftig
grenzübergänge restaurants und
einkaufszentren mit konnektoren
ausstatten damit man doch lieber auf die
epa zugreifen und die impf daten
auslesen kann
was waren was so einfach klingt ist in
der realität dann doch etwas komplexer
als ihre vorstellungskraft und deshalb
war es auch notwendig dass auf eu ebene
die weichen für ein digitales eu corona
in zertifikat gestellt werden sind der
technologische rahmen ist vereinbart
dass bmw hat eine zusammenarbeit mit
firmen mit der entwicklung der app
beauftragt testversion im liegen vor
in einigen regionen er wird es auch
schon durchgeführt der entwickler hatten
neuen prototyp vorgestellt also sie
sehen liebe kolleginnen und kollegen das
projekt läuft das fällt nicht vom himmel
aber der antrag der fdp es überflüssig
wie einkaufen
diese aktive lindner von der
spd-fraktion es geht ja um diesen
qr-code der jetzt findet einer
kostenlosen app auf dem mobiltelefon zu
speichern ist damit sie digital was dann
auch leichter wieder verreisen können
und möglichst unbeschränkt nächste
rednerin ist anke domscheit berg die
opfer der fraktion die linke im
ausschuss für digitale agenda wir haben
vorhin schon beim titel jones
modernisierungsgesetz gehört jetzt aber
zum thema digitaler impfpass nachdem wir
die korona waren app bekommen haben
liegt nun ein antrag der fdp zum
digitalen impfpass vor
für ende juni hat die bundesregierung
ein digitales impf zertifikat
angekündigt für die korona infektion die
auftragsvergabe im märz machte doch
einige schlagzeilen die umsetzung war
mit fünf blocks chains geplant was
keiner recht verstand aber schon im
april wie die block james asuka wieder
eingepackt und die umsetzung erfolgt nun
auf basis einer public key infrastruktur
die ich ein bisschen erklären muss und
da wird etwas technisch das ist ein
system mit dem man digitale zertifikate
wie so ein impf zertifikat erstellen
kann verteilen aber seine echtheit auch
dezentral überprüfen
das alles soll sicher und verschlüsselt
erfolgen in einer bekannten technologie
die zwar weniger hip ist als block chain
aber passender ungünstiger
aber das ist keine hinreichende garantie
für sicherheit denn die steht und fällt
in einem solchen system mit dem
schlüsselmanagement denn ärzte
krankenhäuser und impfzentren brauchen
alle vertrauenswürdige schlüssel sonst
funktioniert das ganze konzept nicht
kein einziger schlüssel darf gestohlen
werden weder in krankenhäusern
arztpraxen oder impfzentren darf ein
system gehackt werden keine mitarbeiter
innen in einer
einrichtungen dürfen gezwungen oder
korrumpiert werden denn wenn das
passiert ist betrug in großem maßstab
möglich das vertrauen ins gesamtsystem
digitaler impfnachweis erschüttert das
ist vor allem aber auch
gesundheitsgefährdend wenn diese
informationen nicht stimmen und damit
der stand der it sicherheit im deutschen
gesundheitswesen halbwegs gut bekannt
ist die risiken aber auch durch alle
anderen eu-länder insgesamt system
gebracht werden
beunruhigt mich die umsetzung in der
praxis sehr und ich kann versprechen die
linksfraktion wird er sehr genau
hinschauen ist jedoch die umsetzung in
einer dezentralen architektur daten nur
auf den eigenen smartphones zu speichern
und nirgendwo auf zentralen servern nach
dem peinlichen desaster um die
hochgehalten ukm ist das eine
erfreuliche nachricht denn viele
sensible daten von potenziell millionen
bürger innen auf zentralen servern zu
speichern war noch nie eine gute idee
darum haben bei uns auf dem land
brandrauch sagt man legt einfach nicht
alle eier in einen korb
weiterhin verspricht die bundesregierung
umsetzung in open source das forderte
antrag der fdp zwar nicht aber er
spricht von stetiger und transparenter
informationen über den entwicklungsstand
weil wir das auch sinnvoll finden
schlägt links fraktion vor
von den lektionen aus der entwicklung
der korona waren es zu lernen nämlich
angefangen vom architektur design und
den prozessen alles auf einer plattform
wie zum beispiel getappt zu
veröffentlichen einen regen austausch
mit der community zu suchen viele fehler
und verbesserungspotenziale frühzeitig
zu erkennen damit am ende auch so etwas
ähnliches wie bei der krone waren
herauskommen kann nämlich eine sichere
und daten sparsam
aber auf das wirken des themas stimmen
darauf weist der fdp-antrag zu recht hin
bei der krone waren app gibt es nach wie
vor defizite noch immer erhalten zu
viele getestete ihre testergebnisse
nicht in der korona werft und das findet
natürlich zu kritik und zum plateau der
installationszahlen entscheidend ist
aber auch die pflege so hat die krone
waren es zwar seit einigen tagen eine
check in funktion die hätte aber auch
schon im alten jahr kommen können erst
diese verspätung macht erfolge von
lückenfüller apps wie die lukb erst
möglich übrigens antwortet die
bundesregierung seit wochen nicht auf
meine nachfrage wann sie eigentlich
davon konkret dafür und das beauftragt
hat bei sap
diesen fehler jedenfalls sollte die
bundesregierung nicht wiederholen
richtig wichtig bleibt allerdings
wahrheit und diskriminierungsverbot
niemand darf zum digitalen impfnachweis
gezwungen werden
die geplante alternative eines papier
ausdrucks mit qr code ist immer statt
app an einer prüfstelle reicht uns nicht
auch andere alternativen müssen möglich
sein nicht nur am grenzübergang auch in
der privatwirtschaft der traditionelle
gelbem papier ausweis zum beispiel das
diskriminierungsverbot muss aber auch
sicherstellen dass ausnahmen von
einschränkungen auch mit anderen
alternativen möglich sind zum beispiel
mit aktuell negativen tests sonst gibt
es ja möglicherweise völlig absurde
folgen wären indirektes reiseverbot für
eltern mit ihren kindern dann
bekanntlich gibt es ja noch gar keine
impfungen für kinder dabei allerdings
müssen wissenschaftliche erkenntnisse
aktuell berücksichtigt werden um
gesundheitsgefährdungen dritter
auszuschließen
eine kontinuierliche anpassung an die
epidemiologische lage ist nötig es gibt
ja auch mutanten vor denen eventuell
impfungen nicht mehr schützen daher
fordert die linksfraktion forschung zur
immunität nach impfungen oder
erkrankungen gerade als
die politikerin möchte ich aber
unbedingt darauf hinweisen es gibt keine
erlösung von dieser pandemie durch egal
welche digitale tools und apps sie könne
nützlich sein
entscheidend ist aber unser aller
verhalten wenn sie sicherheit vorgaukeln
die nicht da ist oder wenn sie kopierbar
sind wenn sich dann menschen riskanter
verhalten erreichen sie exakt das
gegenteil
die linksfraktion wird daher ein
wachsames auge auf den praktischen
einsatz des digitalen impfnachweis haben
und auch darauf dass er zum ende der
pandemie in der versenkung verschwindet
der meinungs- informations-
schwangerschafts abbrüche nicht zum
strafrecht verloren haben § 209 10 a
gehört abgeschafft hier danke anke
domscheit berg ja schon bei der debatte
über das telekommunikations
modernisierungsgesetz sich geäußert sie
hatte einen darauf hingewiesen dass das
virus kroner virus die dumme eigenschaft
hat auch leute zu befallen die nicht
drin die genetisch gehören und sich und
virtuos mit apps hantieren können also
zu denen die im digitalen unterwegs sind
was machen all die sie das nicht können
ein großes problem nächste rednerin ist
maria klein schmeink von bündnis 90/die
grünen einsteigen möchte ich noch mal
ganz deutlich sagen und anknüpfen an die
diskussion von gestern stand heute haben
wir beinahe 30.000 neuinfizierte wir
haben insgesamt eine situation wo wir
darüber sprechen müssen wie wir
wirksam eine wirksame notbremse
hinbekommen wie wir eine trendumkehr
hinbekommen da hin dass wir zu niedrig
instanzen kommen und da müssen wir uns
alle daran beteiligen da geht es nicht
nur um individualrechte sondern es geht
um zusammenhalt es geht um solidarität
es geht auch um die solidarität von
diensten mit nicht geimpften
beispielsweise das will ich an dieser
stelle noch mal wieder klar stimmen und
damit komme ich auch schon zu einem ganz
wichtigen punkt der mich an ihrem antrag
von der fdp so stört in diesem antrag
kommt ist viel von individual rechten
die rede
sehr viel die rede von wirtschaft
stärken aber was fehlt sind genau diese
schlüsselwörter daran zu erinnern dass
wir den zusammenhalt brauchen
gesellschaftlich denn nur so werden wir
diese pandemie bekämpfen können und
gleichzeitig ganz ganz wichtig wir
können digitale tools einsetzen wie wir
wollen damit alleine werden wir diese
pandemie nicht bekämpfen und das projekt
frau kollegen sind inzwischen frage des
büdinger linearen vielen dank dass sie
zwischen frage erlauben sie haben uns
jetzt vorgeworfen wir würden in unserem
antrag frau kollegin karin die
wahlrechte sprechen und über die
wirtschaft aber dass zu den zusammenhalt
vernachlässigen sind sie der meinung
dass es den ankünften ehepaare mit 70
jahren zu vermitteln ist das ein jahr
lang rücksicht genommen hat auf sein
persönliches umfeld die enkel nicht
besucht hat vielleicht im alten- oder
pflegeheim regelrecht eingesperrt war
über ein längsten zahl jetzt endlich
einen impftermin hat wie wollen sie
diesen menschen erklären dass sie obwohl
sie geimpft sind und mit extrem hoher
wahrscheinlichkeit nicht ansteckend sind
jetzt weiterhin aus den gründen die sie
genannt haben solidarität und für die
gemeinschaft weiterhin nicht am
wirtschaftsleben teilnehmen nicht ihre
enkel besuchen
aus falsch verstandener rücksicht auf
andere eben ihre verfassungsrechtlich
übrigens garantierten das hat nichts mit
politischen entscheidungen zu tun
diese freiheit und auch wieder aus
ebenso wie erklären sie das mit
solidarität und habe das für sie nichts
mit individueller verfassungsrechtlich
garantierte freiheit zu tun
[Applaus]
es ist insgesamt ja bezeichnet dass sie
genau diese argumente in diesem antrag
überhaupt nicht angeführt haben weil
dann müssten sie ja darüber sprechen wie
kommen wir denn insgesamt zu einem
vorgehen und frau dittmer hat zurecht
angekündigt dass es im gestrigen gesetz
jahr vorgesehen ist dass eine
entsprechende rechtsverordnung kommen
kann und kommen soll und zwar auf der
grundlage der wissenschaftlichen
erkenntnisse die wir brauchen so und
dann ist es natürlich so dass diejenigen
die geimpft geimpft sind dann
zusätzliche rechte wieder erhalten
müssen oder es geht ja gerade darum dann
einschränkungen zurückzunehmen und davon
haben wir ja gar nicht gesprochen
sondern ich habe davon gesprochen dass
auch wenn wir die individualrechte ernst
nehmen wir trotzdem natürlich den
zusammenhalt und die solidarität sehen
müssen weil ansonsten wird es uns nicht
gelingen diese pandemie zu bewerten und
dann kommen wir dazu der aktuelle
wissenschaft wissensstand in der
wissenschaft in der medizinischen
wissenschaft sagt 5 bis 20 prozent
geimpften personen können sich weiterhin
anstecken sie können bilden dann aber
wahrscheinlich sehr viel weniger virus
lacht last sind damit auch weniger
ansteckend aber insgesamt haben wir
nicht einfach so eine klare sachlage
dieser
kann stand heute können wir jeden
gekämpft
jeder geimpfte person sämtliche
freiheiten einfach so zurückgeben
sondern wir werden weiterhin acht geben
müssen dass die freiheitsbeschränkung
nur den teil umfassen der tatsächlich
massiv einschränken und ist aber
gleichzeitig brauchen wir die akzeptanz
von regeln wir brauchen die akzeptanz
von abstand von vor abstandsregeln von
masken tragen pflicht in geschlossenen
räumen und in pnv und ähnliche das muss
weiterhin grundlage
und dann macht natürlich dieser
impfausweis sind natürlich macht auch
ein nachweis für die dass man getestet
ist sind aber wir müssen eine
wissenschaftlich hergeleitete grundlage
dafür haben und die ausreichende
sicherheit dass das was da zu grunde
gelegt wird auch tatsächlich stimmt und
wir wissen dass mit dem neu auftreten
der indischen variante beispielsweise
und wenn wir uns anschauen die
entwicklung die wir hatten seit anfang
januar bei der b170 virusvariante von
anfang ganz ganz wenig biss innerhalb
von drei monaten 90 prozent im
vorherrschen der des virus teams dann
wissen wir es gibt keine abschließende
sicherheit es gibt kein abschließendes
vorgehen gerade was den impfausweis und
den den nachweis von immunität angeht
sondern wir müssen gestuft sorgfältig
umsichtig damit umgehen und dann macht
das natürlich sind jeder stufenplan für
in erinnerung
der pandemie lebt davon dass wir
natürlich auch einen nachweis darüber
haben ob jemand getestet ist ob jemand
geimpft ist und ob jemand vorher
erkrankt war und voraussichtlich deshalb
auch nicht ansteckend ist für einen
bestimmten zeitraum
und immer wieder werden wir gefordert
sein die wissenschaftlichen grundlagen
dafür immer wieder zu hinterfragen immer
wieder zu gucken wie ist der
forschungsstand das ist nun mal so in
der pandemie und das alles das kommt
viel zu wenig vor in ihrem antrag was
sie im kern gemacht haben ist das
aufzuschreiben was der stand für
jedermann von uns ist wir sind froh dass
es europa europaweit vorgaben gibt für
ein zertifikat ein quelloffenes
zertifikat das war auch ganz klar
gestellt ist dass die europäische
datenschutz verordnung gelten muss das
klar sein muss dass sie interoperabel
ist gleichzeitig klar sein muss dass sie
auf dauer anschlussfähig sein muss zum
internationalen impfausweis der ist ja
der eigentlich die maßgebliche referenz
das sind die punkte die wir brauchen und
da sind wir erst mal auf einem ganz
guten weg da bin ich jedenfalls so wie
ich das bisher beurteilen kann ganz froh
ich bin auch froh dass das in die korona
waren es mit integriert werden soll
was wir jetzt schauen müssen ist dass
wir tatsächlich schnell genug sind dass
wir immer wieder auch genug an
forschungsgeldern beispielsweise zur
begleitung jetzt der virus varianten
insgesamt der situation bereitstellen
damit wir handlungsfähig bleiben und ich
sage ihm zum schluss es wird dauerhaft
nötig seien solidarisch zu sein es wird
noch sehr lange dauern bis kinder und
jugendliche geimpft sind beispielsweise
welche situationen entstehen denn für
familien
wenn alle welt meint ich bin frei
getestet ich bin geimpft und familien
wiederum doch tatsächlich weiterhin
einschränkungen mit in kauf nehmen
müssen das alles müssen wir im blick
haben also wo sowohl freiheitsrechte da
wo nötig da womöglich wieder wieder
zurückgeben aber gleichzeitig
solidarisch bleibt danke
man kann darauf hingewiesen dass die
apps der einzelnen eu-länder ja
untereinander kompatibel sein müssen
oder nicht nur das sie müssen ja auch
jetzt im sommer voll zur urlaubssaison
fertiggestellt sein und das wird viele
länder in der eu vor große probleme
stellen dass tatsächlich in dieser
kurzen zeit hinzukriegen
da gehen dann der satz die hoffnung
stirbt zuletzt nächster redner von der
cdu csu bundestagsfraktion und alexander
kraus ich möchte mit einem kleinen lob
an die fdp anfangen dass sie es
geschafft hat ausnahmsweise mal einen
konkreten vorschlag zu machen denn wir
können ja mal zurückdenken was wir die
letzten tage und wochen hier erlebt
haben von seiten der fdp bis gestern
abend haben sie eigentlich bloß von früh
bis abend ihre bedenken vorgetragen sie
haben gestern erst wieder ihre bedenken
vorgetragen verfassungsrechtlicher natur
aber keine vorschläge gemacht wie wir
das volllaufen der intensivstation
verhindern können denn das ist notwendig
was brauchen wir sie haben im wahlkampf
plakatiert bedenken second was sie
derzeit machen ist bedenken first das
ist ihre strategie diese derzeit fahren
getreu dem spruch von kurt tucholsky
wenn einer nichts hat bedenken hatte
und von früh bis abend von früh bis
abend herr kollege frage des kollegen
sandro hinein ich würde gerne erstmal
weiter sprechen
er kann ja danach und mich dann ja auch
fortfahren es dann dran
von früh bis abend haben sie ihre
bedenken dann aus einem juristischen
elfenbeinturm vorgetragen erst vor einem
monat haben sie uns damit traktiert als
um die im freien folge geht die sie
unbedingt per gesetz festlegen wollen
das ging gar nicht mehr verordnung jetzt
sehen wir auch nach der zeit es war
richtig das so zu machen
die lösung funktioniert und die lösung
ist auch rechtssicher deswegen lassen
sie uns unserem land anpacken lassen sie
uns handeln und liebe ober
bedenkenträger der fdp tun sie sich
einfach mal neu orientieren machen es so
wie sie jetzt mit ihrem antrag gemacht
hat machen sie mal konstruktive
vorschläge
das bringt uns besser und weiter voran
als ihr ständiges herumwirbeln und ihr
ständiges bedenken tragen lassen sie
mich aber auch zum inhalt jetzt auch des
antrages kommen wenn jemand geimpft ist
dann kann er das virus kaum noch
übertragen
ein vollständiger impfschutz tritt nach
14 tagen ein nach der zweiten impfung
aber das ist eben kein
hundertprozentiger schutz dem man damit
erwirbt und deswegen bleibt es dabei
dass man abstand halten muss dass man
hände wasche soll dass das lüften
richtig ist all diesen hygiene regeln
die wir in den letzten monaten eingeübt
haben bleiben weiterhin notwendig ein
digitaler impfnachweis ist sinnvoll und
natürlich ist es am sinnvollsten wenn
auch auf das handy unterzubringen denn
vier von fünf erwachsenen nutzen ein
mobilfunkgerät und die papierversion
wird deshalb eher die ausnahme sein
dennoch auch noch notwendig sein wir
hatten an dieser stelle schon darüber
gesprochen dass es einen europäischen
impfnachweis geben soll
die europäische union daran arbeitet und
wir haben jetzt schon auch darüber
diskutiert wo er so eingetragen wird
wenn jemand geimpft wird wenn jemand
negativ getestet wurden ist wenn jemand
ein antikörper nachweis vorlegen kann
also in letzter zeit erkrankt war und
wieder gesundet ist und das ist
natürlich insbesondere für die
urlaubsländer wenn wir an griechenland
denken wenn wir an italien denken
unbedingt wichtig weil diese länder ihre
gesundheitswesen ihre gesundheitssysteme
nicht überfordern lassen wollen
neu ist jetzt was wir diskutieren dass
wir diesen impfnachweis auch in die
korona beim app integrieren
das ist ein großer vorteil weil wir mit
der krone bleibt die erfolgreichste
tracing app in europa haben mit 27
millionen nutzern und da lohnt es sich
natürlich in so einer anwendung ein
digitales im zertifikat zu
implementieren ich würde mich freuen
wenn wir das nächsten monat schon
hinbekommen könnten wenn man dann die
app herunterlädt und dann auch die
entsprechende möglichkeit hat dass der
imf nachweis dann dabei hast das ist
eine sehr sinnvolle lösung
denn wer geimpft ist der kann und darf
nicht eingeschränkt werden ob an dem
beispiel urlaub oder wenn er zum
beispiel zum friseurbesuch geht oder
einkaufen geht wo man jetzt ja zum teil
einen nachweis ein negativ attest
vorlegen muss der elektronische
impfnachweis ist ein großes puzzleteil
um zu einem halbwegs normalen leben
zurückzukehren zu können deswegen
ermuntere ich uns alle daran
weiterzuarbeiten insbesondere auch die
bundesregierung dass sie da nicht
ablassen weiter voran zu kommen ich bin
sicher dass das eine gute möglichkeit
wird um zum normalen leben halbwegs
zurückkehren zu können
vielen dank für ihre aufmerksamkeit
die bundestagsfraktion der noch mal der
hinweis dieses zertifikat dieser
impfpass soll nicht zentral auf einem
server gespeichert werden sondern weil
jedem einzelnen smartphone wer keines
besitzt kann sich eine digital
einlösbare impft bescheinigung auf
papier ausdrucken lassen mit einem qr
code
gerade ist er nicht so weit gekommen mit
einer zwischenfrage jetzt kann retten
händler und man von der fdp fraktion
meine damen und herren stehe hier mit
einem zettel redekonzept könnte ich über
den haufen werfen was hier für
redebeiträge gerade gelaufen sind ist
geht auf keine kuhhaut mehr
denn was herr kraus gerade gesagt hat
ich frage mich ernsthaft wo waren sie
eigentlich gestern dieser peter barth
und infektionsschutzgesetz wir haben
sechs änderungsanträge eingebracht
vielleicht haben sie gar nicht gelesen
ja nur karten reingeschmissen und nicht
dabei nachgedacht was sie da hat
gestimmt haben kollege tino sorge ich
schätze sie sehr aber sie haben auch in
der debatte wieder impfpass und
impfnachweis verwechselt das in
zweierlei geschichten da ich da hätte
ich ein bisschen mehr erwartet dass herr
differenzieren können denn eine sache es
ist allen klar
im gesundheitswesen sind wir seit jahren
unter digitalisiert und mein eindruck
ist wie die bundesregierung hier agiert
ist wie auf einem sonntagsausflug durch
die lande zu reisen regionalbahn und
druckern daher nach draußen und stellen
fest wie schön ist alles geredet ja
miteinander
da läuft ja auch gar nichts die
digitalisierung ist eine herausforderung
der politik seit 2002 bzw 2014
da ist nichts passiert bisher außer der
redebeiträge sogar innerhalb der
europäischen union sind wähler auf den
letzten plätzen im rahmen der
digitalisierung und dabei geht es nicht
darum infrastruktur zu schaffen
gesundheitswesen die muss
selbstverständlich bürger rechtskonform
und auch der anschutz konform
stattfinden es geht darum dass wir
prozesse gesundheitswesen digitalisieren
wir brauchen mehr zeit für die patienten
wir brauchen mehr zuwendung medizin
wir brauchen auch mehr sicherheit und
effektivität im gesundheitswesen denn so
geht digitalisierung meine damen und
herren
für mich als infektiologe ist der
digitale impfausweis oder impfpass etwas
essenzielles ein gutes beispiel wie
digitalisierung im gesundheitswesen
vorangehen kann ich weiß ob sie ein
bisschen naiv ausweises ich habe man den
fonds rausgeholt zwölf jahre als ist
diese version völlig zerfleddert und
auch da passiert es immer wieder dass
impftermine gar nicht eingetragen sind
und ich sogar als fachmann vergesse
diese termine da ist natürlich eine
digitale form des ausweises mit
erinnerungsfunktion etwas ganz tolles
und auch versorgungs forschung ist dabei
möglich und natürlich muss es eu
einheitlich sein idealerweise auch
international einheit nicht sein ist es
auch bequem und immer griffbereit und
sollen neben ausweis zu haben und
computer das kennt er alle aber wie
sieht es jetzt aus auch für die pandemie
auch da haben wir die chance ein saas
kurs 2 nach heiß oder impfnachweis zu
haben dass man geimpft ist auch gelänge
eine zwischenfrage der kollegin aus der
fraktion bündnis 90 die grünen ja sie
darf ja wohl man danke schön dass ich
fragen darf ich habe ihn jetzt gerade
zugehört und sie haben sehr
breit über den impfpass tatsächlich
gesprochen und auch die chancen eines
digitalen impfpass aber ihr gesamte
antrag in sämtlichen forderungspunkte
bezieht sich ja nun doch auf den
digitalen impfnachweis schauen sie sich
das mal sehr genau an und dann sehen sie
dass genau das verloren ist und wenn wir
uns jetzt schon darüber unterhalten wie
kommen wir denn eigentlich und wie sind
wir im gesundheitswesen mit der
digitalisierung vorangegangen
dann kann ich nur an die wahlperiode mit
mit fdp-gesundheitsminister erinnern und
ich kann mich auch noch sehr lebhaft an
die wahlkämpfe erinnern weil ja daniel
bahr in meinem wahlkreis war
und da kann ich ihnen nur sagen da ist
hoch und heilig versprochen worden dass
diese elektronische patientenakte nicht
kommt und in genau dieser wahlperiode wo
die fdp maßgeblich war ist in sachen
digitalisierung nichts passiert das ist
doch dass das ist genau die
entscheidende wahlperiode gewesen wo
eben der anschluss an die
digitalisierung verpasst worden ist das
muss man ja an dieser stelle deutlich
sagen und wenn sie sich hier so
aufplustern in sachen digitalisierung
sollten sie das doch schon in erinnerung
behalten und deshalb will ich sie jetzt
mal fragen was denken sie denn jetzt
auch als fachmann gerade auch für
infektionskrankheiten wie wir denn
das gericht diesen immunität ausweis
immer wieder auch so auf den stand
bringen dass er tatsächlich die gefahren
die mit mit der infektions lage
verbunden sind damit auch
berücksichtigen können lange lange
einleitung für eine verzichten weil ja
klein schmeink von bürsten bündnis 90
die grünen aber auch die grüne politik
die immer rückwärts gewandt ist und
immer darauf schauen was in der
vergangenheit passiert ist ich denke wir
haben jetzt das freie demokraten klar
gezeigt dass wir vorwärts gewandt sind
und zukunftsweisend was für unsere leute
erreichen wollen das haben die menschen
auch in diesem land explizit auch
verdient dass wir uns weiterentwickeln
und es wäre schön wenn die grünen auch
diese weiterentwicklung auch mitmachen
würden und nicht immer kritisieren was
damals vor 10 vor 20 oder 30 jahren
passiert ist da gibt es genug beispiele
auch bei der grünen politik die auch
sicherlich damals schief gelaufen ist
und heute andere positionierung auch
eingenommen werden ich denke dieser art
der diskussion ist wirklich nicht
zielführend denn viel wichtiger dass in
der politik vorwärts gewandt sind und
immer nach vorne schauen wie es auch
weitergeht und natürlich müssen wir
sehen
und natürlich müssen wir sehen wie wir
diese gefahren auch meistern können und
da kann die digitalisierung natürlich
viel helfen bin natürlich nicht alles
bringen da sind wir uns auch sehr klar
aber wenn wir nur diskutieren und nichts
machen so wie es von der spd auch von
der union vor immer weitergebracht wird
sie haben wir diskutieren darüber wir
haben ja bald ein ehepaar vielleicht
erster januar 2022 oder die eu die dann
auch weiter macht mit einem nachweis
aber das sind immer versprechungen wie
häufig sind wir gerade in dieser
pandemie situation auch vertröstet
worden von lockdown zu locker und also
ich denke diese art der politik brauchen
wir nicht sondern ich kann ich nur
empfehlen nach vorne zu schauen und
zukunftsgewandt die moderne und gute
innovative mediziner hier zu machen
ich komme mir dann einfach zum schluss
meine rede diese pandemie ist es wichtig
meine damen und herren das
geschwindigkeit und gründlichkeit keine
gegensätze sind sondern machbar ist wir
sollten nicht reden sollten machen
es wird zeit dass die bundesregierung
aus der regionalbahn aus steigt und
steigt auf die schnellstrecke der ic
denn wir können das vertrödeln da zeigt
uns nicht mehr leisten digitalisierung
im gesundheitswesen muss fahrt aufnehmen
und deklarieren sie bitte nicht diesem
jahr noch dass die pdf-datei der epa ein
erfolg ist denn wir müssen nicht unser
gegner turbo anschmeißen denn die
menschen des landes habe es verdient und
ich freue mich auf die weitere debatte
herzlichen dank hätte man von der fdp
obmann im ausschuss für gesundheit und
wir sind in der tagesordnungspunkt 12
digitaler impfpass es geht hin und her
die debatte ist ziemlich engagiert sich
auch länger angesetzt war es gibt
längere redebeiträge wohl jetzt zwar
wenig gleich noch zu protokoll gegeben
werden nächste rednerin ist heike
behrens von der spd auch im ausschuss
für gesundheit und vorsitzende im
unterausschuss globale gesundheit und
kollegen wenn uns die krise dann wir
brauchen europäisch ein abgestimmtes
handeln nationale alleingänge tragen
nicht weit sie führen immer nur zu einer
verschiebung des pandemie geschehens und
darum ist es ein wichtiger schritt dass
es ab juni einen digitalen europäischen
impfpass geben wird wir brauchen eine
übergreifende steuerung sehr gemeinsam
vorsorge und fürsorge politik und da
will ich mal eine lanze für die eu
brechen sie steht ja vielfach in der
kritik weil die prozesse langsam und
kompliziert sind aber ich frage sie wo
sie wo liegt eigentlich die alternative
nein wir müssen noch viel intensiver für
ein
europäische gesundheit union eintreten
mit vereinten kräften können wir die
vorsorge und reaktionsfähigkeit der eu
stärken
es ist wichtig des icd sie also das
europäische zentrum für die prävention
und kontrolle von krankheiten zu stärken
und natürlich auch die europäische
arzneimittelagentur weiter aufstocken
und schließlich da werde ich nicht müde
zu wiederholen wir müssen diese
gesundheitskrise in ihrer globalen
dimension erkennen und global handeln
und es ist ein gutes signal dass die
europäische union den sechs nicht zur eu
gehörenden balkanstaaten mit impfdosen
helfen wird auch das kann nur ein erster
schritt sein
dem rasch noch weitere folgen müssen und
zwar am besten über koubeks nämlich den
partei mechanismus für impfstoffe der
weltgesundheitsorganisation
denn auch dies kann man nicht oft genug
wiederholen es reicht nicht wenn wir für
uns in deutschland oder in europa das
impfen beschleunigen es ist zwingend
notwendig in absehbarer zeit eine
grundimmunisierung herzustellen und in
dieser fortgeschrittenen phase der
pandemie kommt es darauf an sich auf das
wesentliche zu konzentrieren nämlich mit
aller kraft die impfstoffproduktion und
medikamentenentwicklung ankurbeln und
weltweit gleichberechtigten zugangs
sicherstellen gesundheitssysteme dort
stärken wo sie heute schwach sind
konsequent weiter testen und einfache
testverfahren vorantreiben und ja
natürlich auch die innovative kompetenz
der digitalwirtschaft dabei nutzen wie
wir es gerade diskutiert haben
es muss doch klar sein
ist ein digitaler impfpass
anschlussfähig sein muss innerhalb der
eu und auch innerhalb der vereinten
nationen
denn kein land kann in dieser situation
dauerhaft mit nationalen maßnahmen
allein erfolgreich sein
für uns als spd geht es nicht ohne
europäische und internationale
solidarität vielen dank vielen dank frau
[Applaus]
zu protokoll gegeben ich möchte bevor
ich ihnen war der teil in dem fall mit
taschen schätze nur der cdu-fraktion
trotzdem ausdrücklich danken und darauf
hinweisen dass nach der bisherigen
planung wie ihr bis heute müssen morgen
früh 4 uhr 10
hier sitzen würden ich werde erinnern
dass wir uns darauf verständigt hat dann
mittwochs zu tagen damit donnerstags
nicht nach 22 uhr tag werden muss ich
möchte daran erinnern dass wir gestern
eine ausgangssperre beschlossen habe 22
uhr später sind es ab 24 uhr ich denke
jetzt weniger an die abgeordneten aber
auch an die mitarbeiter mitarbeiter des
deutschen bundestages hier irgendwie
auch noch mal nach hause kommen wir sind
im zweifel
und ich bitte darum die panther dass ich
am nachmittag schon bereits gedanken
darüber zu machen was man vielleicht
nicht notwendigerweise noch debattieren
muss nach 24 uhr oder 23 uhr die
kollegen kollegen die nicht unbedingt
reden müssen weil sie bereits
aufgestellt worden sind mit sich selbst
zur wahl zu gehen
mit sich selbst zu rate zu gehen ob der
debatten bei trainings ein muss ist und
ich meine das wirklich ernst aber ich
danke noch mal der cdu fraktion ist habe
serien gelegenheit geben man aus der
cdu-fraktion zu lumen an diesem fall
mache ich das besonders gern
[Applaus]
die fraktion ist der letzte redner in
dieser debatte weiß dann aus hin dass
jetzt zwei redner nicht rappen pro gold
geben ihre reden da spart aber fünf
millionen brachte der tatsache dass
heute früh um 4 uhr hier debattiert
werden sollte kein slogan ist zunächst
in norwegen heike behrens für einen
zwischenruf den sie bewusst
missverstehen
weil sie mit zu denen gehört die hier
seit monaten dafür kämpfen dass wir die
pandemie begriff bekommen und danach
schaffen sie es allen ernstes komplett
an ihrem antrag vorbeizureden wobei sie
das gar nicht geschafft haben wie ich
festgestellt habe der kollege herr urban
hat ja noch mal deutlich gemacht haben
gar nicht verstanden was sie von antrag
gestellt haben der fdp hoffen sich beide
teams nicht verstanden haben das hat
ihnen die kollegin klein schmeink auch
schon erklärt der präsident nehme ich
gerne ihre mahnenden worte sozusagen mit
lohnt es sich gar nicht groß hier über
ihren antrag zu diskutieren das können
wir dann im ausschuss machen viel sinn
macht er nicht zur bekämpfung der korona
panne wie macht er auf jeden fall keinen
sinn da es mehr sinn gemacht über die
sorgen und nöte von kindern aus sucht
und psychisch belasteten familien zu
reden die leider dadurch nicht so gut
zustande gekommen sind bei afg antrag
den nebenwerten und eva bremsklötze
schmeißen und nebelkerzen werfen um
sozusagen aus der sache rauszukommen
macht keinen sinn ich bedanke mich bei
den kollegen der cdu und höre jetzt auch
auf vielen dank
[Applaus]